in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Brian
and Debbie are with us hey guys how are
ya good Dave thanks for having us
absolutely welcome welcome where do
y'all live Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
welcome to Nashville that's a bit of a
trip yeah we flew in that's not too bad
then not too bad here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir how much have
you paid off
two hundred and twenty eight thousand
Wow and how long did that take six years
nine months
way to go and making what kind of income
range during that time we made about a
hundred thousand a year and then in 2015
to help push us towards the finish line
we got our biggest year ever and that
was at 1:52 way to go what do you guys
do for a living I'm an airline pilot I
was an airline pilot and then once we
had our children I stopped and did some
odd jobs to help us finish off the debt
and now I'm a stay-at-home mom I love it
very very cool all right
so I'm guessing with the time frame in
the amount you must have paid off your
house yes sir
you guys are way too young to have a
paid-for house you're completely weird
and I love this and you did it in under
seven years how old are you - I'm 32 34
good Ness Wow I love it and what's this
house worth it's worth about three
hundred thousand in Pittsburgh that's a
great house man
yeah we're really blessed that is
awesome a $300,000 paid for house no
debt in the world at 32 years old you
got two little kids what ages and names
said Jennings is three years old and
Creighton is ten months ah Wow life is
good on your planet yeah wow you guys
excellent so what happened six years and
nine months ago tell me this story yes
it actually goes back farther than that
when I got my first airline job out of
college I looked at the income I was
going to earn you know over a 40-year
career and thought I better learn
something about how to manage money
so I just started reading everybody but
I had never come across your material
then in 2009 we got married we bought
this house and we are at my sister's
house my brother-in-law had your Total
Money Makeover book sitting on the
coffee table I picked it up no kidding I
read two paragraphs in it and said I
already know all this stuff and I put it
back down
but God was tugging at my heart that day
to take that book and read it and you
know you don't you know miss that so
took it home read it in one week handed
it to Debbie I said you got to read this
book we're gonna pay off our house and
we never looked back your plan works Wow
very cool so Debbie when when he hands
you that book what were you thinking
well we um we always had an idea of
being smart with money but seeing it
spelled out so clearly and just knowing
what the Bible says about it it just
clicked on all cylinders and God was I
could do this yeah so we just might good
because all the time yeah well so there
wasn't a lot of resistance then when he
hands you the book you want okay I'll
look at it yeah and then you read it you
went oh man let's do this yes absolutely
pretty cool so not not a big fight or
anything to get anybody on board it was
just like it's just when the when the
student is ready the teacher will appear
yep wow you guys are amazing
very very cool so when you I mean none
of your friends I'm gonna paid for a
house I mean hardly any I mean it would
be very weird 32 years old when somebody
hears you have a paid for $300,000 house
they must think you you earn a
half-million dollars a year or something
yeah what do you tell them how do you
tell them you got out of that well you
tell them the secret is well I'll go to
the secrets but we actually have a very
interesting story even before we get
into that in 2011 we were both flying
for regional airlines you know flying
those regional jets around the US and we
decided that we wanted to start a family
and we didn't want Debbie to have to fly
anymore so she could be home so we
started looking at other opportunities
of how we can get rid of her income have
a couple of kids and can and be able to
pay off our home within the 7 years that
we had planned
and so we ended up going overseas for
four and a half years so in July of 2011
I got hired by a company in the Middle
East Wow and we moved over to Dubai what
an adventure no it was an amazing
adventure and the income that we were
earning there we were able to put you
know most all of it on this house and
just January 8th of this year we moved
back home and February 11th we made our
final mortgage payment excellent plan
absolutely love it how fun so are you
flying commercial there or corporate
yeah commercial ok yeah no but as far as
your question about the secrets I mean
Debbie has a good one for that go ahead
well it was a lot of sacrifice I think
people can look and think oh wow you
know they had a decent income you know
they were smart about the money but
there was a lot of sacrifices and not
doing things especially in Dubai the
culture there is is just so over the top
and everything's at your fingertips
so I would say very affluent and a lot
of opportunities spend money that what
you're saying yes a lot but also you
just have to stop with the excuses you
can excuse yourself for not starting the
program you can come up with all the
excuses about my income isn't regular or
you know I have kids they have to have a
great Christmas or they have to have new
school clothes and you just have to stop
with the excuses and you know put on
your shoes and get to work and find ways
you know I did you know I helped kids
learn how to swim for a little bit I
helped at a softball league for a little
bit and then God put a great opportunity
in actually the church in front of me
but if you keep plugging away you know
if you're good with the talents he gives
you he will give you more and you just
have to try and keep going and put away
the excuses preach it oh well done
that's it right there
no excuses well because there's always
something yeah I mean there's always not
matter how much money you make there's
always something perhaps there really is
and you just got to go no this is more
important we're doing that
and uses that out a goal of seven years
and you did it in six years and nine
months three months early it comes in
but you paid a price I mean you move
your family overseas and you know you
said no a lot and and now we're back and
everything set and you're set for life
you really are
we actually have bed sheets that have a
hole the size of our two-year-old but we
were like when we're not getting new
ones until this house is paid off in
that last year yeah we had bed sheets
the hole is huge but for me you know it
was a reminder every night when I went
to bed of the sacrifice that we are
making and now we have some nice news
sheets there you go well I got three
thousand I paid for house you make on
her nails yeah
think you're gonna be all right you guys
are awesome absolutely fun very very
very well done all right
it's Brian and Debbie Jennings and
Creighton Pittsburgh Pennsylvania their
house is paid for at 32 years old worth
three hundred thousand they paid off two
hundred and twenty eight thousand
dollars in six years and nine months
making a hundred up to 152 including a
little stint in Dubai as part of the
program count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
the crowd goes wild
what a great story man I love it
hey listen the one thing you want to
make sure you hear in every one of these
stories and it was right there in front
of you in that story is these people
struggle this is not easy
it's hard but it's worth it
not anybody can get out of debt because
not everybody will pay a price to win
the Bible says no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields the
harvest of righteousness you're gonna
pay a price to win it's how life works
so just like Debbie said no excuses no
eggs you got a feeling that little lady
says no excuses she freaking means it
that's awesome this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind